this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello simpletons welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists dude it looks like
you've been growing that beard out for
like
six months now i had to take ella and
bex to the airport early this morning
so i'm waking l up ella is so she is
negative about everything
of course she's six well no she's seven
oh seven yeah she's like
i don't there's this weird pessimism
about her like
we were at the we went to the beach
yesterday yeah we were at the beach i
can't wait to on the maximum episode i'm
going to tell
you about the insanity that we ensued at
the beach
it was a sitcom episode of the day i can
i tell you
thank you very much for not inviting me
to the beach
yeah uh you're welcome trust me anyway i
woke ella up this morning
and i wake her up very calmly and like
kiss her on the forehead
hey it's time to get up and
like a few minutes later she goes you
know you barely woke me up
what does that even mean i don't know i
have no idea what that means
[Laughter]
and um we were at the beach yesterday
and she was like talking about all the
things she didn't like about she loves
going to the beach
but like she could only talk about the
things that she disliked about the beach
i'm mad that there's not you know some
sort of you know kids to play with or
the waves aren't bigger or the waves are
too big but dude
doesn't she kind of represent us all a
little bit because i got to tell you
i get into that mode but i have the
frontal lobe
to say ryan buddy like don't sit there
and go down that road
don't think negatively however a lot of
the times my impulse
is to go down that negative road of
everything that's wrong why is that i
don't know that's weird well i don't
know there's something about maybe it's
preventing
pain in a way something and that's kind
of what we're gonna be talking about
today because
we are suffocated right we are we are
that we have his friend james wallman he
wrote a book called suffocation
are we ripping off his book title and
that's the name of this episode
suffocated
suffocated his was suffocation yeah but
i think we
we're allowed to borrow from it since he
used our story in the fir to open up his
entire book
what was the name of the person though
no he he used your name
oh but he combined our stories though
right i think he can buy both of our
stories under your name i thought he
called it i thought he called me like
ryan melbourne or something
no no anyway um the the topic today
is suffocation being overwhelmed with
our stuff and obviously this comes up a
lot we have a ton of questions to answer
today so i figured we would just
dive right into some of these voicemails
dude you know what i'm overwhelmed with
right now
why that it's like i've chosen to bring
this into my life
but i was uh i did this community
service event where
we were packing up backpacks and like
just goodie bags for you know families
in need down in uh
it's not south central anymore what is
it south los angeles south los angeles
which totally changed the whole vibe
yeah definitely right you switched the
name and you fixed the neighborhood
right
no uh but they were giving up plants oh
and the whole thing was like hey you're
a volunteer if you want a plant grab a
plant so i grabbed
a serrano plant a couple tomato plants
but now i have to like
get the dirt and like transplant these
plants i got
and like they're functional but having
plants on my balcony for some reason
like it's really stressing me out well
what i love about this is that's a
perfect metaphor because
we take these things into our life
without much forethought
but i did think about it without much
forethought
and and that's actually the that's
perfect because i did think about it i
was at the cash register and i'm like uh
do i want this or this and i decided to
get both
and or whatever it might be really i
thought about mariah
uh-huh i know how much she loves plants
right and i think that's part of the
forethought right
but then what we don't think about are
all of these additional costs
meaning the time and attention and
energy i'm like in this thing of like
soil through my apartment and i'm like
oh i'm gonna have to mop here after i
plug this thing through the apartment
and
yeah there's a lot of other costs
involved that i did not think about
there's certainly there's a psychic
weight now there's a difference with
plants because
they often they're often worth what the
the cost is you're going to go through
and it's going to bring joy to your life
it's going to bring
bring joy to your life you know how many
serranos and tomatoes i'm going to have
for you
i can't wait the podcast on in jordan
yeah so so it's going to be
uh good for all of us heirlooms
but when we bring a lot of the things in
our life i know it's pronounced heirloom
by the way
yes i know when we bring a lot of these
things into our life
what happens is they don't bring the
same joy that plant does
the in fact the plant in a weird way
forces you to take care of it it forces
you to
constantly acknowledge it but with our
material items our dead material items
they're just there the extra clothes
the the the sporting goods the camping
equipment the thing that we just have to
had to have because it was on sale on
craigslist or on sale at
dick's sporting goods or wherever that
thing
just sits somewhere in fact we try to
hide those things
but if you hit the plant it's going to
die almost
immediately yeah and so what i like
about this is like
what we're talking about today is
confronting
the things that suffocate us the things
that overwhelm us
in our lives so let's start with a
question from mckinsey
in tucson arizona now as i'm getting
ready to move across the country to
college i wanted to ask how i should
approach making a packing list and if i
should leave items like
old scrapbooks at my parents house to
collect after i'm done with school
now ryan she mentioned the packing party
so for folks that aren't
aware of the packing party new listeners
real quick
you at the beginning of your minimalist
journey how i started my whole journey
yes 10 years ago yes
i came to you and you told me about
minimalism
and i was like great i'm in now what do
i do right and you were like
we should pack up your stuff and you
should unpack it as you need it
to really figure out what you're using
so we decided to do this experiment for
three weeks
probably took me another three months to
get rid of all the things that i didn't
unpack
but for three weeks i unpacked things i
needed so you know my toothbrush my
bed and bed sheets some clothes for work
the furniture i actually used a tool set
some kitchenware
and it was a great experiment because it
really helped shift my
perspective where if i did it the way
you did it over eight months
slowly but it would not have had the
same impact on me uh the way you did it
what i love about the packing party and
i was talking to dave ramsey about this
we were
interviewing him for this new thing that
we're working on um
it's our next documentary on netflix but
i was down in nashville talking to him
about why do people
get so frustrated and get so overwhelmed
they're suffocated
with most when when they're forced to
move
yeah and when you're forced to move it's
the one time in your life where you're
confronted you're confronting
everything that you own and what i liked
about the packing party for you
is it took something it took you you had
30 years of accumulations effectively
yeah especially 10 the last 10 the last
decade
of mass accumulation right and
it forced you to deal with it in a
attenuated window
of time and in doing that of course it's
a little bit more difficult than if you
were to do something slowly and gain
momentum like with the 30-day minimalist
but for some people
that would work yeah yeah but for me
yeah no the uh
the slow momentum like i just i'm the
type of person that
uh if i want to shift my perspective
like i have to
i don't want to say do something extreme
because that kind of sounds
negative but the packing party is
extreme for all intents and purposes
it's a pretty extreme
experiment it is and we had 47 families
do it at the same time last year for our
new book love people use things which
will be out next
year so um part of that book is we did
this case study on 47
different people and families so it was
some some solo people some people did it
just one room with their house some
people did the whole house
other people did multi-rooms you could
do like the bathroom and the living room
and the kitchen
if you wanted to and we kind of let
people sort of choose your own adventure
with the packing party you did the whole
house packing party
and mckenzie did that once but now she's
moving again
she's headed off somewhere and she's
confronting her stuff again
now she has less stuff to confront and
that's good and then she wants to make a
list of the things she should bring with
her
however i'm going to say mackenzie i
kind of want you to feel
a little bit of this pain right now
because what you're realizing is
man i have to move all of this stuff and
i don't want to have to pack all of this
i want you to have to pack all of it
because i think confronting the stuff
and the the pain that is associated with
moving
and like in ryan's packing part i think
one of the reasons you haven't
reaccumulated stuff
is because you were you had to confront
all of those things and there was a
certain amount of pain
psychological pain literal pain you're
throwing your back out by
by trying to carry all of these items
and there's a certain amount of pain
there
and it's not an unhealthy amount there's
a certain amount of gain
on the other side of this because you're
going to realize that all the things you
thought you needed even after you went
through that first packing party maybe
you held on to some things
that you didn't necessarily need now she
also talked about some sort of
scrapbooks mementos and should i leave
those with my parents what are your
thoughts on that ryan
dude that sounds like why do you hate
your parents mackenzie
[Laughter]
no i i mean here's the thing is if uh
there's two things that i would say
about that particular item
that she you know that she asked about
first off are you
parents willing to hold on to those for
you uh do they want to hold on to those
for you like
are those are those scrapbooks something
that your parents actually want to have
if the answer is yes then great let them
have those scrapbooks
if it brings them a little bit of pain
to hold on to that stuff
then if you know if they're willing to
hold on to it for i don't know you're
going to college for four years
okay i'll come back in four years and
throw those out i mean
that just that just doesn't seem very
considerate to me yeah
um but what i would say is if you are
using your parents place as a storage
unit you've got to have an end date on
it at some point yeah
four years seems like a crazy long end
date to me but you know we're not here
to judge we're just here to relate
i personally mackenzie i would not do
that to your parents but you know you if
you hate your parents go ahead and do
that
i like what you're saying here though
because here's the thing you're saying
if they're feeling a little bit of pain
but part of that pain could just be
inconvenienced
if they're inconvenienced by your stuff
you don't want to do that these are
people you care about these are people
that you love
i don't want to inconvenience ryan or
shawn or jordan or jessica
or certainly bex or l i don't want to
con inconvenience
the people that i care about by the way
i don't want to inconvenience anyone
yeah you want to convenience them right
so i guess maybe the question then
mckenzie is how do you convenience your
parents
and and it does seem a little bit
inconvenient for you to store your stuff
with them i do agree with ryan it could
be an in date if it's not a big problem
for
for them for you to keep some stuff in
the attic or whatever but i would have a
limited number of things a limited
storage
space right even if you look at storage
locker facilities
you're sort of confined to whatever
space you have it's a miracle though
because
people find a way anytime i've seen a
storage locker open up they're almost
always filled to the brim
yeah sometimes my mom's storage unit for
example
when i opened it up like stuff started
falling out onto me like some sort of
cartoon
yeah and and that is what's going on the
storage lockers are suffocating
with with stuff we everything that we
have we're just filling these spaces
why fill your parents space i don't know
that's a good plan
especially that you can since you can
deal with some of that stuff now now we
have a few rules ryan
in fact let me let me give mckenzie a
copy we have a free e-book it's called
the minimalist rule book 16 rules for
living with
less it's available at
theminimalists.comrulebook but
we just recorded the audiobook version
to this but it's not your traditional
audiobook it's
i tell you what ryan this might be one
of my favorite things we've ever done
yeah and it's it's really simple it's
only two or three hours long the
audiobook
but if 16 rules for living with less one
of them is the scan
the photo scanning party which sounds
like mckinsey needs a little bit of that
that would help her deal with the
scrapbooks and some sort of sentimental
items
i think a photo scanning party would
help but i think it would also help you
establish the rules that you need
so ryan and i we went through when we
read these 16 rules for living with less
it's a short book it's about 30
pages or so and what we did though is we
then recorded a podcast for like a mini
podcast for each
rule so if we're talking about the 90 90
rule for example also called the
seasonality rule
have i used this in the last 90 days am
i going to use this in the next 90 days
but then you and i sort of appended it
with additional rules here's how i use
this rule in my life
here's how you can adjust the rule for
you and i think what's going to be
important for someone like mckenzie
especially when you're moving
yes i i get you don't want to pack
everything up then move it
and then maybe go through all the pain
of a of unpacking it over the course of
the next three weeks
well it sounds like you need to have
some rules in place then
and i think the minimalist rule book 16
rules for living with less it's free you
can download it
over there at the minimalists.com
rulebook
i think you'll enjoy that if you want
the audiobook uh it's just a few bucks
but the e-book itself is free so you
have access to all of those
rules we have a question here from
nicole
in louisville i don't know how to get in
the mindset
of consumerism that isn't minimalistic
i can see it afterwards i can see the
after effect of it
but i can't have a minimalistic mindset
in the moment
how can i get that mindset how can i go
day to day throughout my week and not
need to
declutter every saturday and sunday when
i look at
all of the things that i've accumulated
throughout the week so ryan
what i'm thinking about with nicole here
is
the best offense is a good defense
and i'm thinking of like some of the
most well-rounded teams in sports i'm a
basketball fan you're a football fan
and neither one of us know much about
the the other sport right
but battle shot right yeah good job
and and uh safety yeah
all right so what i'm thinking about
here is
there are some players james harden who
plays for the houston rockets
is is a good example he is probably the
best offensive player
see the guy with the beard yes yeah
we've seen him in live in a game in
houston
and so he has that he's got the giant
beard and he's probably the best
offensive player
in the game he may even be some people
will argue he's the best offensive
player of all time
he's really really great at offense he's
not a very good defensive player
this is nicole nicole is great at office
i'm great at decluttering i've got that
mindset i can let go
easily by the way letting go is a
superpower nicole congratulations you
have formed
a superpower but what's gonna make you
better is if you
get a good defense because you have to
let go less frequent in fact
not buying something is simply letting
it go
in advance i love that tweet that
podcast sean
so so ryan let's talk about i mean there
are obviously some rules that we could
we could give
nicole here but she used a word i want
to talk about first
that she she used i can't get into the
consumerism mindset well that's the
problem you're in
the consumerism mindset
there's nothing wrong with consumption
we all need some stuff the problem is
consumerism did she say something like
she said something about the minimalist
version of consumerism mindset which
sounded like an oxymoron to me it is
yeah yeah
so a minimalist consumes intentionally
we do some things whether it's buying
things locally buying
fewer things buying things that have
multiple uses investing more in
experiences
than in stuff but making sure that
everything that we
own she uses the words adds value well
what does that mean it means it serves a
purpose or brings me joy
now serving a purpose means it has some
sort of function brings me joy doesn't
just mean it brings me pleasure
don't mistake and that's where where
nicole is right now she gets pleasure
from consuming these things that's
consumerism i don't care about your
pleasure with respect to
stuff what i want you to get from things
is a function or joy joy means sharing
experiences with other people that
amplify
or enhance your life overall and so
she's here right now in the space where
she's like i'm great at offense
i can get rid of everything my trouble
is i can't stop the
things from coming in yeah i've got a
few rules
yeah i wonder what she's telling herself
like because i'm imagining she comes
across something she wants to buy
and she's telling herself like well i'll
go ahead and buy it because it's going
to give me that dopamine rush you know
because if i ultimately have to let go
of it i'll just let go of it
so it's like this excuse of letting go
to buy something
is i don't know i don't know what's
going through her mind but that's what i
imagine
is probably one of the things going
through her mind but yeah how do we help
her build
a defense towards thoughts like that
well she's got a dichotomy then right
because if she's
if she has that line of thinking i agree
with you it's probably there
where i can just get rid of this later
but then she hates having to continue to
declutter
right yeah well here's what i'll say a
couple things minimalism is a horizon
you will get there
but then there's always a new horizon
you don't actually get to
the horizon and so you do have to
continue to be
intentional with the things that you
hold on to because the things that add
value
today may stop adding value and then
you're going to have to let them go at
some point otherwise you're just
hoarding clutter at that point
however that's going to happen less
frequently if you do have a
good defense so a couple rules that
stand out to me right away these are
also
both from the minimalist rule book the
16 rules for living with less
one that really stands out is the 30 30
rule because
that's the rule that really stops the
impulse shopping we also call it the
wait for it rule right and so if
something costs more than 30
you wait at least 30 hours to buy the
thing
now if it's more than 100 bucks i try to
wait 30 days
and what that does it just puts some
distance some friction in between you
and that purchase because it's easier
than ever now especially with
one-click shopping yeah i mean i can get
it right now we live in
we live in los angeles if i in fact i
don't even have to click anymore i just
imagine it and it shows up on my
doorstep yeah in like four minutes yeah
it's crazy and the problem is when we
have that much
we we get rid of that much friction we
get rid of all the friction we lose
traction and that's where
where nicole is she's lost traction so
she's sliding all over the place
one other rule that i think will really
help out with consumption is the
the one in ten out rule
now this is modeled after you know the
sort of
uh building capacity if you go to a
nightclub and they're like sorry we're
at capacity right
now we're seeing this with corona virus
now you go to the grocery store
sorry it's like we're at capacity yeah
well this is
that rule but on steroids every time you
bring something into your house you have
to get rid of 10 items now you can
adjust that you could do one in five out
if you have way too much stuff you can
do one in a hundred out
right but the the key is that it makes
you start to think about those things
you bring into your home because you
know if i want
one shirt well ten things from my closet
have to leave
that closet before i can bring the one
thing
in and all of a sudden you start looking
at your new purchases a little bit
differently because they they have a lot
more weight to them
yeah yeah i think uh she needs to come
up with some rules herself and yeah the
rule book is a great place to start
because yeah that's our recipe but she
can create her own recipe but the fact
is that she needs to come up with a
recipe to help her curb those impulses
yes indeed nicole i'm gonna send you a
copy of our book essential
ryan and i wrote three books together
other than the the free ebook
but uh we have three long-form books one
of them is called essential so we have
three books one is a
a why two book there's a a what two book
that's minimalism and then the how to
book is essential it's an essay
collection
twelve areas of intentional living i'll
hold it up if you're watching it on
youtube by the way we've got a new
youtube channel now uh youtube.com
the minimalist podcast it's separated
from our main youtube
channel so you can subscribe to either
one of those either slash the minimalist
or slash the minimalist podcast
the the other channel the other
minimalism channel uh is just
the minimalists and they're more
minimalist videos
yeah they're short bursts of minimalism
right and youtube encouraged us
they basically said hey look we are we
fake our site favors consistency
and so put your shorter videos on one
channel put your long podcasts on a
separate channel
and that way your message will reach
more eyes and ears
anyway nicole i'm gonna send you a copy
of essential if you like our
podcast i think you'll really like the
audiobook version of essentials our
longest book it's over six hours long
or if you want the book book or the
ebook version happy to send those
to you as well ryan what time is it you
know what time it is it is time for our
lightning
round where we answer your text messages
you can text your comments
and questions to area code 937-202-4654
yes indeed those texts go to
both of our phones you could also send
an emoji to that phone number
and we'll send you our any like what's
the most recent thing you declutter if
it's a pair of jeans send us a blue
jeans emoji
um if it's an eggplant you got rid of
just send us an eggplant emoji
uh we got the weirdest podcast on just
say peach
[Laughter]
how do you know though what that is sean
did you see that the text we were
we were sharing back and forth this uh
this
sometimes we get weird texts that i
don't respond we try to respond to
everybody's texts
but sometimes we just get some really
weird ones someone
said uh hey josh i know you're a spanker
you need to live up to it
i don't even know what that means i
don't either man what does that mean i'm
a spanker i don't know i mean it depends
if it's someone who's british oh
does that mean or someone who is
american i'm sure
i mean i'm just throwing that out there
that the the definition is very vague
yeah i'm sure it's like depends on where
you're from so yeah i don't know i don't
but anyway you can text an emoji of the
thing you got rid of most recently that
will add you to our
monday morning minimal maxim so each
week monday morning we never send you
spam or junk or anything like that but
we'll text you a little
simple way to start off your week with a
small dose a micro dose of simplicity
each week by the way during the
lightning round that's where ryan and i
do our best to answer every question
with a short shareable less than 140
character response
we put the text to these minimal maxims
in the show notes
so you can copy and share our pithy
answers on social media if you'd like
and now you can find all of our minimal
maxims in one place
minimal maxims.com all right what's our
question this week we have a question
here from
v hall all right v hall
texted in do you guys have any tips on
getting rid of things
during the covid restrictions
so i've got a pithy answer for you here
ryan so getting rid of things during
covet as soon as that question came in i
agreed with it i'm like yeah i guess it
is more difficult
i'm like wait a minute wait a minute so
here's my pithy answer and then one
packet
even the best excuse is still an excuse
why is it actually more difficult to get
rid of things during covet in a weird
way
it should be even easier because you're
surrounded you're confronted by the
stuff more you're at home more
frequently yeah
it's been easier for me man for sure
yeah although finding a place to donate
to has been a little bit more difficult
yes i do have a box of donations sitting
in the back of my trunk that's been
there for
a couple weeks we found a good world
that was open yeah and
it's on uh the one in our neighborhood
is closed i think it's closed
permanently right
there's but anyway there was one uh
neighborhood over basically i'll give
you that yes after all this
but um also you can find places that
pick up stuff for you as well
donationtown.org is a great resource
for you that's what i should do yeah and
so place will pick stuff up especially
if you have big ticket items you have a
big furniture or something you want to
get rid of a couch or a mattress
a lot of these places are non-profits
and you'll find responsible non-profits
in your area
that's how i found when we lived in in
missoula i found the donation warehouse
was from
donationtown.org and they'll pick up
your mattresses and they
they repurpose them to uh people who've
been victims of abuse or
people who are uh were formerly homeless
and they recently have have come out of
that situation
and and they need the essentials and so
you can find a place on donationtown.org
that will help other people with your
stuff that is just
accumulating dust wherever you are you
have a pithy answer for v
hall i do i do before i get to my pithy
answer uh i think with kovid
there's this mindset of you don't want
to declutter right now because
you know we're in an emergency type
situation
and you never know what kind of things
you'll need
but you know to your point now is the
best time
to declutter because if you're saying
you're sitting around with a bunch of
junk right now that you don't need
during covid
you're probably not going to need it
outside of coven or any other
or any other emergency so my pit answer
is this the best time to declutter was
yesterday
the second best time is today yeah so
v hall stop making excuses but
you know we're again we're not here to
judge right um but an excuse is an
excuse
indeed and so you bring up the you you
brought up the word emergency
and i like that because we have another
rule in the the minimalist
rulebook called the emergency items rule
so we
often are allergic to just in case items
because
just in case enables us to hold on to
everything so there's another rule in
that book called the 2020 rule that
allows you to get rid of just the case
items
but there's a small sub set the
subcategory of just in case items are
useful we call that
we call them emergency items and hence
the emergency item
rule and the thing i like about this
rule is it is situational and so
it changes as your life changes when you
and i lived in montana
we actually needed a few more emergency
items right
because there's winter yeah yes and it's
it's not a fun winter there either right
no winter here in l.a
right right here it's like some late
summer yeah
and so uh the thing about these
emergency items we have to be really
honest about what we need
and ryan you hit the nail on the head
covid actually illuminates
how absurd most of the emergency items
we thought we needed
were yeah what about all those buckets
of food people are holding onto right
now like they still haven't had to dip
into the buckets
right right or if they did i i
need to see video of it like right oh i
can't imagine how bad the bucket food is
i think there are we're talking about
the jim baker stuff right yeah there's
like youtube channels where they review
buck bucket food oh wow yeah because i
was like looking at uh
during the earthquake like when we had a
big earthquake i was looking at like
oh how to get prepared for an earthquake
and i came across the
somehow i came across the bucket of food
reviews anyway
it's interesting because dude you're
it's like yeah it's like it's like a you
know a food review
but it's for a bucket of food it's nuts
right now
we did a podcast episode i think it was
with tk coleman
about preparation and let me see if i
can find it here
the thing we talked about though is like
there there are certain things that we
have as
uh yeah it was episode 224 so we'll put
a link to that in the show notes as well
episode 224 of the minimalist podcast so
the title of it was pandemic preparation
but it was really about how little we
need but there
are some things that you and i have like
i have a few cases of like five cases of
sardines now i ate sardines regularly so
it's not like they're
just sitting there going to waste yeah
but that that's my
food bucket effectively i mean i've got
like i probably have two weeks worth of
like freezer
meat meat in my freezer uh
yeah but i mean i don't feel like i need
more than that yeah because even if
let's say the stores closed down
you know i'd have basically two weeks to
formulate a plan
um but having six months worth of food
what does that do because let's say you
are in a situation
where you have to you know have a food
reserve for six months
well what do you do in that seventh
month so maybe you should have a seventh
month of food supply
right i mean it's it's just endless no
matter how much you prepare you can't be
prepared for everything and in that
episode go back and listen to it if
you're interested because
we talk about time frames and what ryan
and i prepare for
and how we differ a little bit as well
so you can check that out episode
224. um we're going to move on to our
added value in a moment i've got three
added values today but they're all sort
of they're intertwined
as one we're talking about stuff right
now
and we're talking about being
overwhelmed by stuff
and i thought about nutrition in a way
how how it relates to nutrition which is
a weird correlation but i think i'll be
able to wrap it together we'll talk
about that also
i know we've got some listener tips but
first i would encourage you to check out
our maximal episode
this week so ryan and i we have
something called the minimalist private
podcast
and this keeps our podcast 100
advertisement free so every week we do a
long form podcast it's
always over an hour sometimes two three
four times longer than our
minimal episodes here but we answer
questions we
we dive deep we're gonna go much deeper
today
on stuff and and being suffocated
here example of a few of the questions
here ryan we're going to talk about
retail
therapy this uh this topic keeps coming
up
someone's agonizing over their junk and
they can't figure out how it can be
responsibly
donated and this other person here is
asking a question about clothing
and being suffocated by their clothes uh
here's one my kitchen counters
are the one thing that always get
cluttered well i've got
i've i have the actual solution to this
yeah if you just make the counters not
so they're at like a
45 degree angle everything will slide
off they just have a cluttered floor
it's perfect no i have an answer to this
because i used to have this
same problem and now i'm able to handle
it even with bex and ella
we have another question here about
getting rid of kids stuff
we have oh we've got a bunch more
questions so so many questions uh oh
something about parents dealing with my
parents stuff
and some of the emotional ties that
overwhelm us
with our stuff we got a lot to talk
about check out the minimalist private
podcast it's a completely
separate endeavor it's just two dollars
and
that money allows us to pay podcast
shawn and jordan and jess and
of course ourselves and for the studio
space
and keep this podcast 100 advertisement
free you can get your
personal link so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app so maybe you listen to this on
apple podcast or overcast or feedly or
whatever
you can just copy that link get your own
private link you'll get a separate
podcast feed to the minimalist private
podcast we go much deeper on these
episodes
you can find all that at
theminimalists.com
support ryan what else you got for us
this week here are some voicemail
comments and tips from our listeners
check them out hello
it is kit calling from toronto ontario
i did want to comment on meditation
as i'm an individual who is very
frustrated
at the beginning of their meditation
journey since i'm somebody who has a
monkey mind
and the traditional idea of meditation
the
sitting closing your eyes and clearing
your mind
just didn't resonate with me so i
dove a little further did a little bit
of research and i found out that
meditation is actually more about
being in the present moment and once i
was able to wrap my
mind around this concept it was a lot
easier for me to actually
have a mindful practice in everyday life
whether i'm doing the dishes or the
laundry
any mundane task can be meditation
it's as long as you're being mindful and
you're being present and you're being
aware
so keep in mind that individuals who are
maybe frustrated with the traditional
ideas meditation
you can actually meditate when you're
dancing when you're going to the gym
a walk in the park or even when you're
watching tv
it can really be anything that you enjoy
as long as you're present
and in the moment hello i'm lady from
brazil
and this is for the lady who asked about
minimizing beauty products
first don't let social media like
pinterest and instagram compel you to
consume
it's easy to mistake inspiration with
comparison to me minimalist beauty could
be about enhancing what you have
instead of spending time and money
trying to change it i found freedom in
embracing my natural hair texture and
color
i found a hairdresser who knew how to
properly cut my hair type
then minimize the time and money spent
to try to change it about makeup you can
minimize the amount of stuff
by owning multi-purpose tools like a
beauty blender that replaced all skin
and concealer brushes for me
get rid of repeated items and throw away
expired makeup as you can grow bacteria
and cause breakouts
and don't feel bad if you paid a lot for
something and need to toss it
if buying an item made you happy it
already served its purpose
all right joe for our added value today
we're suffocated with stuff right
and to me we're almost malnourished by
our stuff
here's what i mean by that you and i
grew up when we were growing up we were
both
we were literally the two fattest kids
in our grade yeah if you go back to
september
2013 on my instagram at joshua fields
milburn you can find a picture of me
who's i was mullet and all yeah the only
reason i know that was people i
mentioned on one episode that i can't
find it you have to go back
whatever that is september seven seven
years ago yeah but it's a picture of
of me at age fourth grade yeah somewhere
around fourth fifth grade something like
that
uh 1990 or 89 or so so i was obese
and it was right around the time you and
i met i was the fattest kid in school
you were the second fattest kid in
school and we ate a lot
meaning we got a lot of calories macro
nutrients
but we were deficient in micronutrients
and so
it we continued to eat but we're never
sort of satiated
we were never nourished by that food and
i think the same things happen with our
stuff
a lot of the stuff we have an abundance
of calories
the average american household has
hundreds of thousands of items in it
but there's no they're not nutrient
dense items
right and yeah i think that
is also true in our our everyday life
in terms of what we eat quite often we
don't understand
that we need nutrients in our food
rarely do we think about the micro
nutrients that are in our food so my
added value today
are three things i would recommend to
you ryan uh to
sean to jordan anyone who's listening to
this there are three things that
recently have really helped me out the
reason i'm feeling a little bit better
health-wise
is because um we've been on the right
track with three things
number one is there's this tart cherry
jell-o that bex has been making from
scratch
and it's two ingredients it's literally
two ingredients we'll put a link to that
sean i just sent you the link uh we'll
put a link to it in the show notes
but it's tart cherry juice yeah and
it is gelatin yeah which are animal
bones right um well yeah i mean it's
synthetic animal bones now a lot of the
time oh no no no no we get the good
stuff
oh oh i understand what you're saying
yeah what i'm saying is you can't get
synthetic though like for the vegans out
there yeah no no you don't want to do
that for this okay not for the oh
because you're
because of the because of the nutrient
density of the bone right right
and it's not just bonus cartilage and
everything just so you all know jello
has always been
bones by the way yeah it does yeah are
there alternatives i'm sure there are
but but that's what it's made from by
the way
that's the original jello yes and and so
you want a high-end one i think great
lakes is the one we use
or natural layer whatever they are um i
got this from
from ben greenfield by the way two of my
added values there from ben greenfield
uh and so this jello it helps with a few
things i pulled up this article here
it's tart cherry they they're so it's
not like
jello you i mean it it looks and feels
texture wise like jello but it's not
full of all the sugar and stuff you
used to so i have one square of this
every night and here are some of the
benefits
uh digestive health health detox so the
glycine
is the big thing that's in the
cartilage and stuff yeah
joint health skin
health and it's because it's because of
the
the bone material the yeah it's not the
bone but the cartilage and everything
else that that's in there so
uh but it's none of the negative
downsides of
um of if you were to buy store-bought
jell-o it's not fresh it has
preservatives
yeah so here's all all we do we put it
on the stove
heat it up until it's all mixed together
just the
the juice and and the gelatin gelatin
and then you pour it we put it into ice
cube trays like these big rubber ice
cube trays
and then we refrigerate it and then
within a few hours it's ready to go and
then i have it for several weeks at that
point i put it in
into a bag or a container and this i'll
eat one at night beck's will have one a
night
but it really helps with the two things
i haven't talked about yet
are inflammation and sleep so because of
the autoimmune issues i have it's really
helped with my
inflammation overall that's great and
then it helps with sleep there's a study
here
in this article from lily nichols that
i'm going to put out there lily nichols
handles a lot of
the stuff so she she's the one the
article i sent you sean
but uh there the glycine in gelatin
has been shown to help you sleep better
and there's a link to a study here
and so ben recommends this you know a
half hour to an hour or so before you go
to bed
and that's when i've been doing it it's
been like this really nice dessert and
that there's
just enough tartness or sweetness in
that cherry that
it does kind of feel like a dessert
isn't it crazy how when you cut out
like the vast majority of sugar yeah all
of a sudden something like what you're
talking about it's
it actually tastes like a dessert a
little bit it's a treat yeah it's like
like when i eat an apple now i'm like
god this is so sweet too sweet yeah yeah
right so
so i would definitely recommend these
you can make them they're really
inexpensive
um the second thing i'm going to
recommend is this tummy healing yogurt
so it's this coconut yogurt i was
talking to mariah when you and mariah
were over the other day with the uh
not the slow cooker but the what do you
call it it's a slow cooker yeah it's uh
so
we it's like what is it called it's the
bot it's the pot thank you yeah
we make yogurt in an insta pot yeah and
which is basically a slow cooker but yes
yeah there's a yogurt setting on it it
takes about 36 hours we got some
at home right now being made and so this
is a coconut yogurt
and so this is this one is vegan if
folks are vegan who are listening
bacteria though is that vegan like you
would think that like it wouldn't be but
it is
yeah probiotics they are little living
microorganisms yes they are
but i think it's it still counts as
being vegan if you are a vegan
um but it's really helped my stomach
these last few weeks
uh there's a particular bacteria
bacteria in it
and i'm just gonna put a link in the
show notes to
this has been greenfield his two twin
boys have a podcast called the go
greenfield
show yeah and they did the cutest thing
with their dad they made this
um this uh mood boosting
secret recipe for coconut yogurt it's
this gut healing yogurt
but there's a lot of science behind this
but it was just really cute watching
these two kids or hearing these two kids
make it
and i sent it over to to mariah this
morning because she was asking about it
but it's this yogurt and then i what i
do is i'm working my way up to half a
cup a day and
it's really it's really helping my gut
heal i feel like now
to what extent it will long term i don't
know but man
so you're saying you're working up to a
half a cup like it's pretty medicinal it
sounds like
uh yeah someone like you would probably
be fine you already have a healthy gut
it would just make your gut more healthy
what it's going to do is seeding your
gut with this bacteria so if you ate a
half of a
cup it would mess with your gut yes i
see okay
okay yeah it should be too many
probiotics at once for me so i'm working
working my way up cool
anyway i'll put a link to that in the
show notes and then third and finally
uh there's a supplement company that
i've really been getting a lot of
benefit from ancestral supplements
i'm bringing them up i've heard of them
um so it's organ pills basically
so okay so i just do straight up
raw liver right but so so i i don't
so i do a bunch of different organs
through them so i i do and this will
grow some people especially if you're a
vegan but i'm like 99.4 percent of the
world i'm an omnivore
um and and so the most nutrient dense
parts of the animals are the parts that
we don't eat right right
liver or well yeah brains brain yeah so
i do brain pills
i did some right before i came in here
um so it's desiccated so it's
freeze-dried so it doesn't remove all
the nutrients from it
uh liver i'll do heart kidney uh there's
they have this this organ blend that has
like heart kidney and a few other things
in it yeah um
i i do the intestines the stomach and
intestines that has really helped my
stomach as well
yeah so they have these intestine pills
and then um
they have a prostate formula so you can
if you're if you're a guy and you want
to
you know enhance your vitality as they
say yeah
uh you could do that but if you just go
to amazon look up ancestral supplements
they have some of the best reviews
you'll ever see just look at their
reviews
now i've mentioned them just in passing
one of the time on the podcast
and they they reached out to me and they
were like hey can i send you a bunch of
free stuff thanks so much
and it was actually the owner one of the
two owners of the company
and i i was really flattered because i
spent a ridiculous amount of money on
their supplements
right and i had to say no right because
and it sucks to say no because i'm like
i would love to have some free stuff
yeah
but then you feel obligated i'd feel
obligated but i also wouldn't feel like
i could recommend them
genuinely yeah and so what i've decided
is no you can't send it to me i'm going
to continue paying full price for your
supplements
but i am going to be able to mention you
and feel really good about mentioning
your company because
i don't get anything from you nor do i
want anything we're 100 advertisement
free
you can't pay us anything to advertise
on this podcast
but if i find value in your product or
service then i'm happy to mention it
either in passing or as an added value
segment it was like
every dollar reached out to me and
they're like you guys talk about it so
much can we give you the
i'll just we'll give you the free uh
premium and i was like we'll do two
things
the premium kind of takes some of the
work out of it and the work is painful
for me
okay so that's why i do the free version
uh but also i was like look you guys are
awesome and if i really
wanted the premium version like i have
no problem supporting your company and
giving you whatever it is per month for
the premium version right it's not even
that expensive either
right yeah yeah with these supplements
it's a little bit different yeah but i
spent a couple hundred dollars a month
on supplements but here's the thing
it's really helped me it's helped my
mental acuity it's helped my
inflammation it's helped my gut health
these aren't panaceas it's not it's
literally not a magic pill but if you
don't want to eat
heart and kidneys and brains and spleen
yeah and intestines yeah i might check
out the spleen intestine brain stuff
because we i
we do a ground beef from u.s wellness
meats
that again no sponsor here uh that they
grind in
kidney and heart and liver into their
their ground
it's like a 50 50 blend um but yeah the
brain stuff
i don't know if i i don't know if i i
mean i can eat raw liver i've done raw
liver shooters like based on paul
saladino's recommendations
and i do notice a little bit of a of a
difference in my
mental agility or um just my energy in
general like
there is something there but with the
brain i don't know if i could eat raw
brain
i so the the where do you even buy a raw
brain you you can't
you have to slaughter the animal
yourself but i've seen people do it
sadly but
um i would definitely wouldn't recommend
anything raw because there's a lot of
food safety
obviously right yeah um yeah i do raw
liver that is yeah i would not recommend
anyone else do that
right right yes there could be food
contamination issues now
you get really high quality and uh yeah
et cetera et cetera but still
even still especially if you have gut
issues like i have yeah
there could be some potential issues so
we have we have three added values here
the the tart cherry jell-o homemade
talk about nutrient dense also helps
your sleep helps your inflammation helps
a bunch of other things
link to the article in the show notes we
have the tummy healing yogurt you can
check out the go greenfields episode
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes as well
if i were to recommend just one out of
these three things and right now would
be that tummy healing yogurt for me
although i think long term if i were to
recommend one thing it'd be the
ancestral supplements because
and there are some others i do long i
mean think about rest so
what they do is like supports like so if
you
are consuming heart it's because you
want to
uh you want good heart health really
yeah yeah that's that's sort of this
ancestral principle right
and so think about liver when you do
liver you want to
you want a better liver now what does
your liver do well everything
it detoxes it processes and so
it you're able to improve everything
well if i want to improve my my
intestines my
you know i've got all these ulcers in my
my um small intestine
of course i want to consume uh that part
of the animal then right
and i want to do so safely and
conveniently and these supplements have
i mean i i noticed a difference the
first week i started taking this
so maybe try just like the organ blend
to get started or if you want like the
the brain or something like that
but just go on to amazon and take a look
at ancestral supplements
look at the reviews i'm not telling you
to get it it's really up to you
but these are parts of the animal we
used to throw away right
and so in a weird way like even if
you're vegan
these are parts of the animal that would
have 20 years ago ago
maybe even 10 years ago gotten thrown
away or mixed into some sort of
uh slop but you know it's interesting
though you go back
far enough and they were the most prized
pieces of the animal
yes and they still are in some and then
post-industrial yeah like that's when it
started
to get thrown away yeah they're the
let's talk about the reason they're most
prized
because they're the most nutrient dense
they're what make
you feel the best and that's what i
really care about
i don't care about what your diet is if
you're a carnivore
like 0.0001 of the population
if you're a vegan like 0.4 percent of
the population or zero point six percent
of the population
feel good if you're an omnivore like me
and ryan and most people i know
then i i want you to be able to feel
good on whatever diet you are and
no matter what you're doing if you're
like our friend rich roll who's been on
this podcast a bunch
he thrives on a plant-based diet uh if
you're like our friend paul saladino he
thrives on an animal-based diet
but the people i really see thriving
most of the time are the people who
combine the two
in a smart intentional way that serves
them
yeah so i hope you enjoy those three
added values i was going to recommend
today
i i saw this palm springs uh film
on hulu that's not my added value
yeah but i i wanted to i thought it was
funny um we
try to watch it with ella and it's a
it's a romantic comedy okay
it's a romantic comedy let me just say
that again okay
romantic comedy okay ella sits down to
watch it with us
and there's this hilarious scene where
where the main character
gets shot by an arrow like it's so silly
and
and ella freaks out she just starts
crying yeah and then
you come over last night or whenever it
was two nights ago yeah
with mariah and we watch these
documentaries that are truly terrifying
animals getting eaten by snakes and
stuff yeah
she doesn't get scared of that at all
yeah but a romantic comedy just
terrifies her
yeah that is that's crazy so that's not
my added value
but um i i don't know what to say about
it dude i uh i'm trying to remember
the name of taylor swift's new album
dude
it's not terrible
i'm just throwing that out there that's
not our added value either but i was
throwing that i want to recommend the
most popular album of the year
is it the most popular definitely yeah
oh okay yeah
anyway i've only i've only heard bits of
it but what i heard was was really good
i've had several people recommend it to
me too yeah
so i'll have to really dive deep into
that one uh right here right now here's
one thing that is going on in the life
of the minimalists now ryan we
have been doing this for 10 years now in
the last 10 years we we've
been on nine different tours
and we've been all over the u.s and
canada
australia the uk we've been all over the
place
and looking forward to hitting the road
again soon
until then we have all
any tour stop that we recorded so we
either did audio we did video for some
of them
you can find them on our website
theminimalists.com
previous that gets you to our previous
tour stops
and you can see a list of literally
every tour stop we've ever
been on and if it's clickable that means
you can see
the video or hear the audio via
any or for any of those tour stops now
unfortunately
later this year well earlier this year
we were right before covet hit we
were getting ready to go on this tour
the west coast tour yeah
and uh we had a post pull on it because
of kovid right
stupid coven yeah roon and everything
and and so we postponed it till november
yep well i just got the phone call from
live nation
and wme who represents us on these tours
and they've decided to cancel virtually
all of their dates for the rest of the
year
especially on the west coast yeah and so
uh we we are a casualty of that i guess
it's no longer the less coast towards
the lost coast tour
because this is gonna be our lost tour
this is gonna be our
our year of not touring yeah and uh
last year we only did one event in 2019
yeah
so when all of the dust settles from
covid and we have
found our new abnormal we'll hit the
road again yeah
you can get our email list over at
theminimalists.com
tour and we will update you whenever
coming to
a city near you but uh yeah that last
coast tour
we had to contact all 16 guests for it
it was going to be phenomenal
but it is now the lost tour yeah it's
not something we can reschedule because
next year we've got a book coming out
and um of course our new film will be
out as well so we're going to move
beyond that hopefully we can get some of
these folks who are going to be on that
tour as podcast guests here in the
studio
at some point it'll be great but it is
i guess it's the lost tour now yeah but
that's okay you can go back to all the
previous tour stops
any of the ones we recorded the
minimalists.com
previous to find those tour stops and
listen to them watch them
and enjoy the the past letting go
all right you can follow the minimalists
on facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalist
come to one of our live podcast shows
once we
start doing those again at
theminimalists.com
tour to find a city near you if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast email a voice memo to
podcast at theminimalists.com
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalist and if
you want our show notes
in your inbox sign up for our email list
over at theminimalists.com you'll also
receive our simple
sunday emails whenever we send them if
you leave here today with just one
message
we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it